foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr
chandeloni Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and coach for the Dr
John baloney show is my co-host today as
we answer your questions about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the call is free and some say the advice
is worth exactly what you paid for it
Braden's going to start us off in Denver
Colorado this hour hey Brayden what's up
hey guys well um long time listener and
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
how can we help my question is um
it's a very long story but um basically
my mom has no money
um and she's 62 and I'm wondering how I
can protect myself or prepare to
um I guess just help her in retirement
um so that's it and I'll let you guys
maybe ask the questions okay financially
and legally you don't have anything to
protect yourself from
so there's her if she has dead it
doesn't leap over to you upon her death
it just goes away with her so that
there's no issue there but the only
issues then your sounds like you're
wanting to help her in this situation
and and then that's a whole nother
barrel of Fish Hooks right
yeah yeah basically I feel like I'm
cornered a little bit in the sense of
I either take relatively full
responsibility of taking care of her or
she she kind of ends up on the street
um is what I feel like I'm I'm facing do
it again she's what happened to your dad
um he was tired of supporting her they
got in a divorce about five years ago
and she's pretty dependent on depression
and anxiety pills and basically went
numb
um and she's been numb for about seven
years and I would say she's addicted I'm
not sure if that's a if that's a real
thing or not it can basically okay so
basically um she's really dependent on
those and um is very very depressed and
basically my dad said I can't support
her lifestyle because because legally he
was supposed to be doing that
um and so he fled the country and
um he's I don't know I think he's in
Thailand right now basically
it was a hard decision for him to make
but he said
um hey I love you but I've got to go
because the court system's making me
give her money and I can't I can't
continue to let her do that to herself
so are we talking about uh uh alimony
yeah basically my when it all happened
my brother was 16. oh child support and
he's 18 now
yeah well well you know and I don't know
exactly what it is Dave who took care of
your brother who took care of your
brother
well my mom was your dad didn't feel an
obligation take care of his kid
no well well my brother is addicted to
marijuana and what my dad was doing was
he was giving them thousands of dollars
a month and and realized that he was
supporting two drug addicts and my
brother was stealing money from my mom
to buy his marijuana and he just said I
can't I can't see is he out of her house
now
yes he he left he dropped out of high
school and he's living with his
girlfriend and his their family
apparently what's your setup right now
are you married how old are you yeah I'm
29 married
um followed you guys a lot and that free
baby steps four five and six awesome um
just had our first baby
um and we live in Wyoming household
income
uh about 100 120. okay
Dave I've got an opinion but you've seen
this way more than me you dive in
brother my because I gotta I got a
feeling I'm gonna be right on your
coattails Brayden I here's the thing I I
it's easy for me to sit up here and say
I wouldn't do anything like you don't
have to do this and she gets to choose
whatever
I also know like my mom is in her 70s I
I wouldn't be able to sleep at night if
I didn't sit down and at least say
here's the best way I can love you and
here's the skin in the game you've got
to have to make this thing happen
and so I I a couple of things that play
here one you've got to sit down with
your wife and decide as a couple what is
how far are we willing to go is that
move mom in is that send some money
somewhere like what how far and how able
are we to go and borrowing money and
making this whole thing mess bigger for
your for your generationally is not an
option right so how can we what are we
willing to do and if nothing is on the
table then nothing's on the table but
y'all need to have that conversation
together the second thing is you know
this that um
whatever narrative you have from your
dad from your mom it's it's way more
complex and way more of a mess than that
and so I think you need to keep all eyes
moving forward not trying to untangle
the past it's too messy you don't know
all the things
um it sounds like one of those if your
dad's willing to walk out on your your
brother willing to walk out on his
responsibilities then it may be one of
those situations that her over the years
her addiction was uh to cover up a whole
bunch of other mess in the house all
that to say is this
you get to say hey Mom here's what
here's what um I'm going to require of
you to participate in some sort of
support or help if you choose to do that
and the hardest thing in the world I
can't think of another harder thing than
to watch someone you love
make choices not accept care not accept
responsibility not accept help and
you watch them fade away it's it's one
of the it's one of the most difficult
challenge I think it's the most
difficult thing um we can do is to watch
loved ones fade away
Braden I had a good friend who um
drank himself to death he drank until he
died and I killed him his liver went bad
and he kept drinking the doctor said you
got three months to live if you quit
drinking and a month later he was gone
because he didn't
um and I sat with him I'm like dude you
know you might as well just put a gun to
your head it's the exact same thing put
the bottle to your head I mean it's just
the same thing and I I there's nothing I
could do
nothing and there's no word to say I
mean he's going to do what he was going
to do I couldn't like stop him and like
John said it just tears the heart out of
your chest somebody you love you know
running running the car in the ditch and
you're sitting here going hey just turn
you know just keep it in the road you
know and um it's very very difficult to
watch so I the first thing you have to
do is you have to protect your wife and
your child and your future
that's your primary obligation beyond
your any obligation you could have to
your mom anything you do for your mom
that interferes with your wife your home
and your child and your the future of
your family is an improper level of care
no matter what no matter what she does
okay
she does not get the right with the life
she has lived to interfere with your
future to the point that it just that it
destroys your child's future you have a
baby that you are the father of that's
your primary goal having said that then
if you want to love her well then you
need to require some things of her that
are good for her she needs to be seeing
her therapist she needs to be monitoring
her meds she needs to be she's going to
read she needs to go to rehab she needs
to get a job she needs to be on a budget
that you look over her shoulder and make
sure she's managing the money that she
has well she can get on Social Security
and it'll go a long way towards keeping
her from being hungry do not give her
cash give her groceries pay her rent
directly but only if she's doing steps
that are going to you know that's going
to facilitate her having a Dignity of
agency again standing on her own two
feet again I'm sorry man I hate that for
you man
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
hey you guys can help us and a bunch of
you have been we appreciate you we know
you have been because our numbers are
going up substantially on podcast on
YouTube and on radio and we appreciate
that so here's how you can help we don't
spend like eight bazillion dollars on
marketing you guys are our marketing you
tell other people and that's about the
only thing we got we don't have any
stadiums named after us like survey and
so excuse me sneezing but the uh um but
yeah I don't I don't we don't do any of
that kind of stuff
um and so
if you can if you want to help us
subscribe to the show if you're a
podcast or YouTube uh uh consumer we
appreciate that you can leave a
five-star review one Stars don't help
Mama said if you ain't got nothing nice
to say don't say anything at all five
stars all we need thank you very much
move on if you don't like it it's okay
and um and what's the other thing you
can do oh you can uh share the show and
that means you tell people some method
or another how you're consuming the show
we're watching it on TBN we're uh
listening on our local radio station
there's 680 of them that carry Us in the
nation by the way uh there's uh we you
know you got an actual share button on
podcasts and on YouTube so share it
subscribe and leave a review you'll help
us out a bunch John
the questions for human cards are
officially
a uh a mega hit they're part of the
Ramsay lexicon now man oh I'm I'm yeah
that's that was a goal I don't even I
had to look that up yeah okay so wow
it's a big deal yeah so you know those
moments when you're sitting next to
someone and you feel a thousand miles
apart
um you're staring at your kids uh I my
son turns 13 today so happy birthday to
him but we were sitting across from each
other at Waffle House this morning happy
birthday big Hank we have uh breakfast
together every Tuesday there's been some
of those breakfasts I'm staring across
from my 12 13 year old son I don't know
what to say I don't know how to say it
or he says things like fine good good
fine fine good some 13 year olds are
aliens most of them most of them are but
these cards have been amazing and so
listen you can put your phones down and
we've we've substituted deep and
meaningful conversations for binge
watching Netflix scrolling social media
you deserve better relationships your
kids do your spouse do your grandparents
too everybody does it's why we created
questions for humans conversation
starters that will help you disconnect
from your screens and actually connect
with real human beings we have a deck
for everyone dating couples girls night
guys night parents kids friends
everybody work and uh as we've talked
about over and over it's been hard to
keep them in stock we've got them all
the decks will get you spending time
laughing together learning something
unexpected and building deeper and
stronger relationships pick up one two
five ten all kind of packs find them at
ramseysolutions.com
humans so if you guys don't know what
he's talking about with it's like a deck
of cards and you just draw one out and
it's got like a question like the
funniest thing happened to you in
college or something like that and it
starts a conversation and when my
daughter finds out that like
I went on my daughter's favorite thing
she's seven is she asked one of the
questions is what's a what's an old date
that went horrible and I told her that I
went on a date with somebody
she's still to this day she's like what
does she think about like whenever no
matter what we're doing she thinks it's
the funniest thing ever but we've been
able to yeah you actually had a date
before her mom right yeah and oh my
goodness well what does she think about
the house if she's shocked that you had
a date before your mom everybody was
shocked yes every friend I had was
shocked
um but it just it just created a whole
new
um interaction point and again I'm
embarrassed to say that uh I found
myself like I'm gonna grab these cards
because I'm starting to get disconnected
from my own kids they're great and you
wrote them yeah yeah I wrote them yeah
but they're great man and they've
flying off the shelves flying a massive
massive success all right Patricia is
with us in Fort Lauderdale hi Patricia
how are you
I'm doing well hi Dave hi John hi well
how can we help
okay so I'm hoping you can help me solve
a debate with my husband okay we both
have really uh good incomes between us
both there's like 220k we have some
savings uh 150k
um we are debt free we're doing 15 of
growth into Investments
um stock Investments and we're at this
point now looking for a home
okay
like 400 to 450 and the house my husband
would like to move into is about 250k
um we've seen some in this area they're
released
okay your phone's breaking up you're
going to speak directly into it you saw
some in this area that what
you saw them in the area that are 250k
this is my husband's Branch yeah and
they're you make 225 000 a year you have
150 000 in savings
yes what do you do for a living
oh so I work as a software developer at
University of stock Trader he works as a
what
a doctor a stock Trader of Betty does
okay and
um
yeah how long you all been married
of three years okay
all right and so he he he's what 26.
no he's 47 I'm 47.
I missed that one why does he want to
buy a 250 000 house
because he's a cheapskate and he's a
player
into a volunteer family home yeah he's a
player he's a stock Trader yeah he's got
always got does he always have a scheme
on top of a scheme on top of a scheme he
does yeah okay here's the thing
um my advice to your husband
is that you separate being a player
from where you live
okay
p-l-a-y-a yeah
from where you need to separate it from
where you live
because you don't play with your home
this is where you live with your animals
your future children and God help you
your wife okay
this is where you live you don't play
high risk
maximize investment games with your home
it's a safe haven it's a place it
happens to be a good investment but it
is not a speculative we're going to make
a bunch of money investment in the short
term and that's how his brain works so I
know this guy because I used to be him
that's why I said 26 because when I was
26 I did the same thing we moved so much
our furniture was trained to jump on the
truck
because I was a player I was always
wanting to do some deal and I pulled my
poor wife around by the hair on her head
and she went along with it and we've
been married 40 years and she tell 40
years she now tells people we've had 33
good years of marriage she doesn't count
the first seven right and that's because
of stuff like this right here so I can
speak directly to him I was him when I
had hair okay that's it so the uh the
best thing he can do is separate
relationally psychologically investment
philosophy separate your home from your
investment mentality
it happens to also be a good investment
by the way but you need to separate it
out that's my advice to him and my
advice to him also is happy wife happy
life you guys can afford a 450 000 house
he needs to go get a 450 000 house and
then he needs to do his other stuff
after he gets that house paid for
you win the argument
hey Patricia
are is he always running a scam does he
always have a thing going there's always
something I think you've been married
three years at some point you need to
have that conversation because this will
keep coming up and it'll come up in all
sorts of different areas when your
parents start aging when you've got to
think about retirement facilities it's
always going to be another thing you
have to sit down and like Dave said
you've got to be really clear and
intentional about boundaries we joke
about it now at our house Patricia but
when I'll start working on something if
Sharon smells that she looks at me and
she says you're scheming and scamming
and meaning I'm trying to I'm trying to
use my intellect my mathematical skills
to out finagle reality
then that's what she's telling me you
hear me
in other words I'm violating Common
Sense here because I'm starting to just
go off in some little corner of
something with some math riddle and
figure out a way that I can maximize
something that wasn't intended to be
maximized like the place you live or to
get what you want right yeah yeah so if
he wants to do fixes and flips he should
do that with cash after your personal
residence is paid for and is a
sufficient resident you've been living
three years in a one bedroom apartment
you make a quarter of a million dollars
a year you've already sacrificed time to
get a nice house 15-year fixed where the
payments no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their one
guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Eric and Stacy are with us
hey guys how are you doing great thank
you awesome cool where do you all live
Colorado Springs Colorado oh very nice
very nice welcome to Nashville and how
much data have you paid off a hundred
and forty thousand dollars cool how long
did that take 43 months good for you and
your range of income during that time
started off at 60 and then it went up to
about 160 165. nice jump in three and a
half years yeah what do you guys do for
a living
I'm a police officer I'm a client sales
manager okay so sounds like you sales
managed a bunch yes sir like your income
went way up good job well done Eric well
done yes because police officers don't
usually get a hundred thousand dollar
raise in three years well the 60 was
starting off with just my income
um and then when she got her job and
then another job that's when it kind of
built into that extra and your income
didn't go up during that time yeah
absolutely okay good what kind of debt
was the 140. our house wow
wow talking to weird people that's right
how old are you two weirdos I'm 34. I'm
35 and you're a paid for House in
Colorado freaking Springs oh my goodness
what's that house worth
a little over 400. I love it how much
you guys got in retirement
around
um 350. wow so by the time you're 40
you're gonna be worth about a million
and a half that's the goal
oh yeah
like an assassin
assassins
get in your way
I love it all right so what happened
what happened how'd you get on this
crazy adventure
so we took Financial Peace University
like two years into our marriage and
then
life kids were in our third house and
then we took a class at our church and
then I started working part-time doing
Financial advising and I was like we can
do this
then first we were like let's do it
before we turn 40 and then I started
working more and more and more and I'm
like on 20 21 the very beginning we set
a resolution let's do it before 2023.
and then we did it right before we did
it in the end of September and then 2022
yeah and then Nicole was born a couple
weeks later yeah so covid was behind you
when you got real serious and leaned in
did it motivate you that all that
garbage you'd just been through
special yeah for me it didn't really
change anything yeah you're pretty much
Essential yeah yeah yeah but I'm saying
but looking at that going oh man this
life can happen we better be more
prepared did that enter into the
decision or what caused you to all of a
sudden flip the switch and go game on
desire just just wanting to be debt-free
okay yeah you look down saw the numbers
that's all you could is that what you
said there
I think it was more like we I started
working with other people with their
finances and seeing like this is all
about Behavior
you know and we started working I used
to say that you're not allowed to say
that it's not Behavior it's just uh yeah
it's the math problem right
um and so we were like we just have to
do the right thing and so I started
working more and more and we put all of
my income into just additional principal
payments and we just kept living off of
Eric's income which we started this
journey with and we just pushed and
pushed and pushed wow so if you continue
to work
yeah yeah so how uh how does it feel to
be completely free
awesome yeah just like the total weight
off your shoulders yeah your shoulders
my shoulders
true but I mean you don't have a payment
in the world no that one yeah what's the
first cars are all paid off for and
everything what's the first big thing
you do after you pay off your house
I bought a motorcycle there you go of
course she did what'd you get uh Indian
Chieftain oh nice beautiful so wheat
good for you well you should you should
pay for and of course it's paid for
Stacy what'd you get
besides the third human well here we win
here
oh the trip to Nashville that's right
there we go very good very cool we're
proud of you guys you're Heroes man 34
freaking years old your house is paid
for that's impressive in a culture
that's completely lost its mind I mean
you guys in both of your worlds you see
it every day everybody's a victim and
you're not you're not a victim of
nothing you're just a Victor yeah Eric
do you have uh hard conversations with
some of the folks you work with I spent
my my whole life growing up around
police officers and everybody's got to
have a Jeep or a big truck or a thing
and uh I can imagine you had some hard
conversations telling your buddies now
or your co-workers this is I'm doing
something a little bit different
definitely being content with what I
have and not you know there's definitely
desires to go out and buy everything
that I could
um but you know looking back at home and
having to bring it you know bring a
brand new truck home would not you know
be a good thing to live with so
um you know the desires were there but
you just have to have the the
to drive to not do it yeah live like no
one else so later you can buy a
Chieftain yeah I mean yeah here we go
yeah I like it it's awesome good job you
guys hey we've got a cop the uh live and
give bundle for you a copy of the baby
steps Millionaire's book you're going to
be that very soon as we said and uh The
Total Money Makeover book to give away
get somebody started on their journey
and in your world Stacy you'll be able
to do that pretty quick and a membership
to Financial Peace University another
probable giveaway for you guys but it's
all for you to live and give bundle and
bring the kiddos up let's introduce them
find out their ages and names
what are their names and ages
so this one here is Kimber she's five
this one here is McKenzie she's seven
and this is our newborn Nicole she's
five months go Nicole I love it yeah
very cool house full of girls a lot of
women
girl power I love it very very cool what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt-ish
I think it's discipline and living below
your means like we could have easily
just increased our lifestyle when I
started working and instead we had
discipline to keep our lifestyle the
same and just pushed it yeah and I'm
looking at three little people whose
lives are changed and their whole family
tree has changed because of 43 months of
you guys being in control way to go very
proud of you all right Eric Stacy
McKenzie Kimber and Nicole Colorado
Springs 140 000 paid off house and
everything that's right your weirdos
make
debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
very very very cool
so a a financial advisor and a policeman
are going to be millionaires about the
time they're 38 they'll be out about a
million and a half by the time they're
40.
um
don't tell me it can't be done
geez and they'll have three kids that
aren't teenagers yet it's just amazing
yeah and they're you know and we call
them weirdos you guys don't understand
78 of Americans live paycheck to
paycheck that means if you drive down
your street you count 10 houses eight of
them have too much month left at the end
of the money to have a paid for house is
statistically highly unusual especially
at 34 years old so that's weird normal
sucks normal is broke normal is out of
control normally spending like you're in
Congress and you have and Sallie Mae's
been with you so long she's got her own
bedroom in your house normal as you live
from
MasterCard to master card bill how'd
they name that anyway oh they knew
exactly what they were doing yeah man I
mean that's normal you don't be normal
people and those guys right there are
weird no kidding and to think of the as
as they mentioned they both had their
unique cultures that you got to go into
every day it's tough going to the police
culture those guys don't they work
really hard they got a lot of stress
they don't make a ton of money the the
incentive to buy something cool is heavy
it's just it's just a culture Stacy
going in to be work sales every day man
that's gonna be hard because you're
making good money and it's hard not to
be like I just gotta get a new car just
to continue to see that eye that prize
keep your eye on it man that's tough
it's tough tough tough tough paid off
their house pay out their house and you
know what if you drive like no one else
later you can drive anything you want
whatever you want yeah I mean I drove a
really nice car to work today I saw it
but I drove some crap he passed so I
make no apologies for what I drive now
paid a price to win and there you go you
always pay a price if you're going to
win there's no way around it those guys
did very powerful so proud of you guys
this is the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Colton is with us in
Dallas hi Colton welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave hi John how are y'all doing
today great man how can we help
so
um over the last two years I've been
able to pay off seventy six thousand
dollars in debt
um still owe sixty six thousand dollars
my wife and I have been talking about
downsizing our home
um to pay off the rest of it we owe
225 on our home and it's worth 3 45.
um and part of that debt is we have
solar panels now you know 18 000 on
so part of my question is would it be
better to
transfer that eighteen thousand dollar
loan to the next homeowner
or and I forgot to mention this we just
got an inheritance of about twenty
thousand dollars
um should we go ahead and pay off the
solar panels or should we try to sell
the home and just transfer the loan the
house will have the solar panels will
have to be paid off when the house sells
you can't transfer the loan
okay because the there is a lien against
the property and so the cloud the title
is clouded
and because they're attached to the
house okay even if they didn't file a
second mortgage it's it's an encumbrance
on the property and so depending on your
state I'm not sure exactly how Texas
would address that they've got a little
bit of unusual real estate laws but
either way I it there's a lot of danger
in transferring it if you didn't get
your name off fully and then they didn't
pay it later
um then the solar panel comes after you
because your name's still under there on
the paperwork they never get out of
there or something along those lines so
I what I want to do is just make sure
they're paid off now you can either pay
them off now or you can pay them off
from the sale of the house if you're
selling the house you're 100 sure you're
selling the house
uh it's just something we've been
talking about
um that and that's part of the question
too do you think that's a smart decision
to downsize you know find how home with
a mortgage of about two hundred thousand
dollars
um so we can pay off the rest of that
debt
no no you've already paid off 76 000
you'll be able to pay that house off if
you like the house you want to stay
there or think about the math here you
said you got 66 000 left is that right
no oh
yeah 18 on the solar panels and then 48
in student loans okay so you're gonna
sell you got 200 uh we got 100 something
in equity left
like have you sold your house right now
yeah
so you're gonna take
20 000 of that and put it down on the
house which is gonna lead it's not it's
not worth the math it once you take that
20 grand that you just got from The
Inheritance put your debt down to 40 and
then you'll just hit the hammer on it in
the next 12 months and get this thing
paid off yeah just like you did on the
76 and knock it on let's be done I mean
you're so close man yeah and just just
have your first mortgage solar panels
are paid off student loans paid off and
you're gonna do that and how long did
you say you took to do 76
uh it's been almost two years to the day
we started April 21st y'all just tired
right
uh yeah
you've been working a lot
yeah yeah you're so close man how old
are you guys
uh I'm we're about 27. good okay
um let me tell you I think you're going
to be done if you take the 20 and throw
it at the solar panel and you stay and
you reset your budget tonight reset your
energy tonight I think you're gonna be
done in about a year
okay I think it's gonna fool you okay
and because the you know sometimes uh
people get almost there and just before
they break through they quit because
that's what everything with jobs with
yeah it's not it's not unusual so you
just John John heard it clearly it's
just a there's a it's not even a
physical fatigue it's just emotional
fatigue
yeah you just get uh you know you just
feel like it's a slog
um I used to do half marathons and
there's a point at out of the 13 miles
at the nine nine and a half mile Mark
where you cuss yourself for running a
half marathon for about a mile you think
this is the dumbest thing any human has
done why am I doing this again and
you're so stupid you signed up again you
know I mean just you this is you talking
to me talking to me right but it's a
slog and then there's you keep on and
about the 10th mile about when you turn
10 you go okay I got three to go and you
can start to see the end and your energy
level comes back up and your pace comes
up but usually my slowest Mile in the 13
is somewhere around that ninth Mile and
it's not unusual it's a fairly normal
it's not but it's an emotional wall that
you hit there from the slog more than a
actual physical wall or in your case an
actual physical wall from being so tired
from actually working all the time so
you're going to be there in about a year
and when you're 30 and you look back uh
you're you're not even going to remember
how much pain this was all you're going
to remember is the victory and you said
something important
um just from the the Neuroscience world
I think it's important if you've got 150
000 let's say and you pay it off 100
it's taking you two years y'all are at
the end of your rope twenty thousand
bucks falls out of the sky for you
there's something powerful about taking
that hundred off and doing a like a
complete control delete reset okay we
got 50 grand left we just got 20 in the
mail now we got 30 we can do this and
it's a it's a it it's a re-energizing
right so it's like get to the end and
saying oh it's got four miles left or
I've been got 13 I got three miles I can
do this right it's a no difference I've
done it a lot I can do three miles it
has nothing to do with having already
run no matter what I can run three miles
that's it there's a there's a reset
there that
um but it's almost like you need to wad
up your old budget and throw it away and
get a clean piece that's right control
delete yeah clean clean the clean the
white board and go okay let's write this
out as if we were just starting
okay we can do this yes and it gives you
that it gives you that that whole thing
and that's where you are dude you can do
this and you're going to call us back
and you're going to do your debt free
scream and we're gonna brag on you we're
already bragging on you you've really
had good progress I'm real proud of you
all right Lou is in Pittsburgh hey Lou
welcome to the Ramsay show
great man how can we help uh I just have
a question about I'm not sure how
familiar you guys are with uh I took a
lease back loan where you can buy a
model home
um from a building company and they pay
you rent until the entire development is
done and then you have the option of
moving into the home and changing your
loan from like a commercial loan to a
conventional loan or selling the home
after which it appreciates because
they're building all homes around it
um
what to do right now so I'm just kind of
getting advice okay uh I wouldn't do
that
for multiple reasons let me give you the
reasons okay it sounds really good on
the surface
um the the the problem is it only works
if it works
and I like to have deals that are happy
happy deals we call them there I'm happy
if it doesn't work and I'm happy if it
does work this one you're only happy if
it does work so here's here's um uh your
number one we tell people not to borrow
on investment property to pay cash for
it so number one number two you're
putting commercial paper on investment
property it has a whole different set of
terms the boilerplate documents are
different the call Provisions are
different uh it's what got me broke when
I was 28 for for instance one of the
call Provisions is a standard commercial
paper that's not in a normal Residential
Mortgage is uh if they decide the
quality the collateral has gone down
they can just call the loan
they can just decide that they don't
like the quality of the collateral
anymore so what could cause that well
the Builder could get in trouble because
real estate has slowed down and interest
rates have gone up uh if the Builder got
in trouble and he doesn't finish out the
whole area guess what all that
appreciation you were thinking about is
going to not be there and guess what
then you've got an area where there
might actually be some houses that are
half done that don't get completed
because the Builder's in trouble
builders get in trouble all the time in
economies like this by the way and
that's your tenant they don't pay now
you've got to pay but even then the bank
looks up and goes oh I know lose current
but uh look at all the weeds and the
half completed projects up and down this
street and look at the number of
foreclosures on this street we're not
only not seeing appreciation we're
seeing a neighborhood deteriorating
because the Builder got in trouble did I
mentioned that builders get in trouble
sometimes and um now this is what I've I
used to buy properties after the Builder
got in trouble so I know what it looks
like I bought it I bought a whole street
of properties one time I had to go to
finish everything clean up the weeds and
became the guy that finished it out but
I bought it for nickels on the dollar
yeah after this not before this so
yeah don't don't do it all right no
there's a lot of other Investments that
you can do this sounds like a sure thing
but it's only a sure thing to the extent
that the Builder
doesn't get incredible and they do all
the time dude so especially in
environments like this so I hope that
helps
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work
that they love and create actual real
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five John sometimes people
wonder why I say we help people build
actual real relationships and that's
because you and I have made this in
unbelievable discovery that in the
current century there are people that
are starting to realize finally
that Facebook friends are not real
friends they're not real friends it's
not a real relationship the way you tell
somebody that you love them is not an
electronic thumbs up it's not not that's
not how love is transferred these days
you can't click a like nope
click like I like you you can it's just
it's Gonna Leave You Hollow we used to
send these little notes up and down the
aisle in elementary school oh yeah
remember those things yeah yeah and
you'd be like you're dumb you're ugly
well you you like Dave ooh
Brody grip yeah remember that word doing
something tactile about it and you can
see them there was an actual human over
there yeah not a digit yes you weren't
arguing with a bot with the zero one one
one one zero yeah man yeah it's a
different world so it turns out that
trolls
are the mean people on the internet
when you meet them
are highly disappointing individuals
yeah they're really kind of sad little
cowardly people that don't that in a
real world would never be that brave
they just and people who are mean on
Facebook and gossipy if you ever sat in
a room with them would never have that
kind of Courage we call that digital
courage so it turns out real actual
relationships are something that we
specialize around in here and it's kind
of like common sense
and it's really marketable in America
today so it's like a discovery your
Facebook friends will not help you
change your tire at 2am
well and it's not one of them it's that
uh Dave it's that
um you know the criticism of Ramsey
Solutions is you know you're just you're
just giving people common sense that's
where we are that's where 100 and uh
unashamedly I'm giving people like and
I'll charge you for it since you haven't
got anything turn your phone off and
talk to your children and I'll show you
how to do that yeah yeah
have a conversation John will sell you a
deck of cards to help you do that I got
you
if you don't know how to tell your wife
hey this is what I need I will help you
out
yeah saying a wild world man it's a wild
world well it's um Dave people are crazy
it's it's
I but you know there is there is a
there's a relationship Revolution yeah
that's starting to occur where people
are saying it's not okay
to sit in a restaurant and both of you
send texts across the table
there's people starting to understand
that that's
sick yeah I I uh Dave I saw some
students that had they they took all
their phones and they stacked them up in
a pile and the first person who grabbed
them had to pay for the whole meal and
they are they are they are practicing we
realize we're addicts we're gonna
practice just sitting at the table
together yeah I love it I love it I love
it so for five years I've been trying to
learn how to play golf and um that's
another story we'll go it's another type
of a problem in addiction but um anyway
aside from that uh one thing I've been
practicing is I I have my phone on the
golf course well I mean golf is a really
ridiculously difficult complicated game
for somebody like me that is limited in
athletic ability and so
um add to it distractions of crap coming
from the office on the iPhone so I just
I I my new thing is for four hours I
don't look at it
okay how do you feel when you do that
are you are you angsty or do you feel
free you know for a little while I I was
it was like an addict it was like I was
being taken off the pill right or taking
off the the drug but now I kind of look
forward to it yeah and there's this
piece when you come because there's an
agitation that goes with the constant
screen check there's a 2500 times a day
somebody it's those numbers are typical
people 2500 2500 times a day they check
their scrapbook grab it grab it it's
like
you know it's just like I just got
dinged I got I just got like that
unfollowed oh my God I'm rejected by
somebody I didn't even like did your
golf game improve considerable really
what's all about concentration anything
that that interrupts you because if
you're thinking I was playing with a pro
and he said his sports psychologist says
uh okay after you hit every shot in the
round we're gonna we're gonna grade
we're gonna step to the side in grade uh
a five is you were thinking about
nothing but the golf ball a one is your
thinking about buying a car when you get
home okay right and so and he said and
then we go back and we take the one to
fives and he said guess where my best
shots were well duh right where you were
concentrating on the shot well guess how
life and reli and relationships work
you're married caught the same right
right guess what you follow I follow a
guy out of the neighborhood the other
day my little HOA he's it's you know six
o'clock in the morning still dark he's
swerving all over the place I'm like
he's drunk at six o'clock in the morning
no
just texting it was a contractor setting
up his Subs while he was driving and
he's swerving he's driving like he's
drunk with a stupid phone like okay
decide are you going to drive or you're
gonna be on the phone you drunk you know
get out of the way too by the way but
yeah oh my gosh but that's it's hard to
do that thing that phone thing and
anything else right but here's the other
side of it and and you noticed in short
order
I I get itchy without it and then I go
four hours and suddenly there's a piece
and my golf game is improving and I've
not gonna crave it and I can't wait to
get out there because I don't have this
thing a few weeks ago uh
my Sheila my wife left left town and it
was just me and Josephine and Hank and
Hank had something he was going to so
just me and Joe and I just told Sheila
I'm gonna get off the rails we're gonna
go eat every donut we're gonna go eat
like a pancake breakfast at a restaurant
where like me and her are just pizza and
chocolate cake it was 24 7. Madness
um her blood sugar wasn't so great but
everything else listen since that
weekend where I put my phone away and
she had my undivided dad's gonna be with
you for breakfast for lunch for dinner
I have a whole new relationship with my
kid like she comes in hugs and when I
wake up in the morning and it was it was
literally day 48 Hours it was 48 Hours
of I'm just gonna laser in on this
little girl and to to control to lead
our relationship it's amazing it's
really amazing how quick it comes back
around well that's the good news it'll
heal back yeah bad news there's a dozen
if you don't put screen down put it down
you gotta put it down and screens aren't
evil but the overuse of them and
substituting that for real connection
and real relationship is evil I'm
starting to think you you say you've
said for 30 years that money is is a
byproduct of of your marriage a
relationship like what you got going on
your life it's not the problem it's the
same I'm starting to think uh screen
time is too if if you're sitting there
at a restaurant and both of you are
staring on screens and you're on a date
with your wife
that's that is the the smoke coming up
from the fire it's like assuming you
ever knew how to do a relationship
that's right that's right we have a
segment of uh the demographic that has
never been without a phone in their hand
right and so they don't know how to
break up except by text
I tell you what man I had a student come
in that got his wife left him a divorce
via text and uh clocked Dave listen I
said what are you doing in my office why
aren't you going home and this is a
direct quote
we have a zoom conference set up for
Friday and I was like you should
probably just get out of my office
good grief we have a zoom concert
because she texted me
uh why are you here
we're so real relationships it's part of
what we do here this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Luke is with us in
Cleveland Ohio hi Luke welcome to the
Ramsey Show
good afternoon gentlemen it's a pleasure
to speak with you you too how can we
help
well I'm either on baby step two or baby
step seven and I need a little
clarification to figure out which one
I'm on okay
uh so I have a credit card which I don't
want to have a credit card but uh with
where I'm at in my life I'm fortunate
enough that I can take a trip to Mexico
or to the Caribbean about twice a year
and on all the debit cards I found they
all have a two percent uh foreign
transaction fee and my credit card does
not so I do have the credit card but I
use it for the time when I'm at the trip
and then I pay it off the next the
following month when it the bill comes
due you know that's interesting I got
back from Mexico Sunday and I haven't
been there 10 days and I didn't have a
single charger talking about on my debit
cards
really yeah
because I've called two they just asked
me do you want to run a place you want
to run in pesos or dollars when they run
the little machine out to you
yeah no and it's always in dollars and
that's still apparently a two percent
fee at my the two credit unions and two
I just booked a trip to
[Music]
out of the country in the South too and
they had the same I think we just made a
better debit card a different bank but
anyway even if you're I mean we we would
tell you to get a different better debit
card because we don't believe in credit
cards at all but even then if you use a
credit card and you paid it off what's
your problem you're not in debt
that's not a baby step two thing
well I mean this I guess there's a bill
but it's not really I guess a true debt
but also I'll keep my credit score which
I don't really want and yeah that's a
problem I know something something that
you talked about before so
confused on what I should do well um
number one here's the thing the amount
of pain that you were in before because
of your stupid money decisions will
dictate how drastically far you go with
these things I went completely broke so
I don't walk anywhere near a bank except
to make a deposit
okay I can't stand those people even my
banker who's a friend of mine I'm not
sure I like no I'm kidding but uh but
you know you know what I'm saying right
and so uh it's just the whole thing and
so there's no chance
even if I wasn't the guy about no credit
card Dave Ramsey guy I would have a
credit card because of what I've been
through You by listening to you have not
had that I've been that burned
experience so it's a little bit more
yeah whatever for you and I get that
that's not a criticism but I'm just an
observation is that fair
yeah absolutely yeah so again what we
teach is based on this absolute I'm
never going to go near a dead instrument
again because I'm never going in debt
again so that would dictate for someone
doing that that they go and find a bank
that doesn't have ridiculous fees on
their Internationals and I'm really
shocked your credit union does I would
talk to them about just removing that
because credit unions are very very
um customer oriented much more so than
banks in general and they don't want to
lose a baby step seven customer yeah but
you but if you have a bill that comes in
during the month like um
your electric bill and you pay it you're
not in debt if you had a credit card
bill that came in and you paid it you're
not in debt you're on baby step seven
you're just on baby step seven and you
still have a credit card which is the
only thing I would obviously have just
griped at you about but yeah but that's
the you know but you're a baby step
seven guys where you are to answer your
overall question and um yeah I dude I'm
in Mexico three or four times a year I
like Mexico and so
um
uh um and
I you know I do have to watch the peso
exchange shifting a little bit it's gone
from uh 0.2 to 0.18 and so it does
affect things a little bit you have to
watch what you're doing uh and and
sometimes they'll catch you with a
conversion if you're not watching your
math
in some of these locations but that's a
that's a vendor issue that's the uh the
merchant that's not the credit card or
the debit card so we use our debit cards
uh frequently we use a lot of cash too
Mexicans much prefer cash by the way
um for the same reasons a lot of
Americans do but even more so they don't
want the government after them so that's
the whole thing they don't want the
government knowing they like being off
the grid as much as we do uh those of us
that are rednecks okay so we don't want
to be on the grid either we don't want
um anybody knowing where we are so
that's very interesting a good question
Hannah's in Pittsburgh hey Hannah
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you
thank you for sure what's up
um I was just wondering if we should pay
our mortgage or if we should wait until
we have a little bit more saved
um that's like a safety net
okay do you have any other debt
no okay you're fairly new to this whole
Ramsay stuff aren't you
yes okay so we teach a process called
the baby steps
and it's how to apply it's the next step
the next thing and then the next thing
and the next thing a clear path from
where you are now to wealth first things
get a thousand dollars second thing is
be debt free but the house you've done
those two right
yes okay then the third step is to have
a fully funded emergency fund grandma
called it a rainy day fund the proper
amount is three to six months of
household expenses what's your household
income
um well I just I just click job so now
it's going
okay are you going back to work
stay at home mom for a while okay how
much is your house payment
good work Anna wow okay that's weird
that's wonderfully weird okay and so
um
okay so let's pretend that your monthly
expenses if everybody's income stopped
uh that you could live easily on uh four
thousand dollars a month I wouldn't be
far from wrong would I
no okay three times four is twelve
six times four is twenty four so you
should have an emergency fund of 12 to
24 000 before you start paying off your
house how much do you have in savings
okay let's allocate twenty thousand of
that to your emergency fund now
everything else is going towards your
mortgage
how much is your mortgage balance
um about ninety two thousand great okay
so you said you have ninety five
thousand in savings
yes
okay
um well the the way we would teach it is
you keep your emergency fund of three to
six months we could call that 15 for fun
that'd be putting 80
on the house
and uh then you pay off the house what
by Christmas
if you only have 15 old right and then
if you want to build up your emergency
fund a little further you could that's
what we would do around here because no
house payment is going to make you even
more brilliant than you already are and
you're Pretty stinking brilliant good
grief I love that that was like a slow
flex and we have a 95 000 and 600 house
payment that's a good test translation
Hannah you are well on your way before
you ever met anybody called Ramsey but
we'll help you get it get there even
faster so Dave one of the one of the
criticisms I get is this is this
situation
how do you tell somebody like because
mathematically that's it kind of went in
the lottery the 650 house payment
there's but there's the the umbrella the
shadow that sits over you that says
somebody else you owe money to right you
owe money to somebody else
how would you explain that to somebody
that says no it's worth it to go ahead
and do it
it's worth it to go ahead and pay that
thing off even though your house payment
is so low relative to what you're
bringing home every month
because
several things happen in addition to the
math being freed up
the first thing number one the math is
freed up and now you can invest and save
and and be generous with your entire
income and it will cause you to be
wealthy faster that's the basic thing
but it's only 600 bucks for freeing up
here so it's not like it's a ton but
it's there and whatever else extra they
were paying or putting into savings so
she's got this vague savings over here
that hasn't got a real assignment yet it
doesn't have a mission the second thing
that happens is
um that people that don't have a single
piece of debt you talk about this they
relax in a place they didn't know was
tight
their relationships get better their
employment changes for the better
because they don't have to work there
they're uh the qual their health
improves literally yeah I mean the
hypertension that we've faced in this
culture yeah you know anxiety people
with mortgages don't have as much high
blood pressure hello wow just think
about it people that don't have
mortgages have peace Financial Peace two
words that don't go together like
Airline service this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Corey and Amber are with us
hey guys how are you hey David John good
to have you guys where do y'all live
Raleigh North Carolina oh fun that's a
great town we love Raleigh Durham good
good so how much debt of you two paid
off
558.11 wow give or take way to go and
how long did this take two years and
five months all right love it and your
range of income during that two years
and five months we started at 95 000 and
now we are a little over 200 000. nice
double in two years so how'd you double
your income in two years
well starting about beginning of 2020 I
didn't realize how much debt we actually
were in it's primarily student loan debt
Amber finally shared it with me and I
said I'm tired of all this money going
out the door and not being able to keep
it so we got that gazelle intensity I'm
a mental health therapist and so when
March 2020 hit unfortunately covet
impacted a lot of people's mental health
and therefore you were kind of in the
Plexiglas business right now buddy yeah
yeah mental health and plexiglass big
deal during covid right yeah wow wow you
just took client after client after
college yep
oh man that's exhausting work it is it's
like walking through spider website long
hair when that started yeah I did I did
all disappeared
wow that's a lot of therapy without
without getting any and Amber uh what do
you do for a living I'm a reseller and I
have a small YouTube channel oh cool
what do you resell clothes and shoes
really anything and everything what do
you do eBay or Facebook Marketplace eBay
Poshmark mercari Facebook Marketplace
what's the most successful which
platform
it varies it changes depending on the
season the years but eBay and Poshmark
are pretty much the top two for me I've
met people that are buying clothes at
garage sales for 10 cents and selling
them for three dollars on eBay and
they're making 10 grand a month I mean
people doing that I was afraid when
covet hit that my sales would decrease
because it went up they did because
people didn't want to leave their homes
so online shopping well and they're
bored they're just sitting there pinging
on buying stuff
then they feel ashamed so they call you
got to figure it out and they gotta get
back up here you guys got a racket
all right so what got you all started on
this two and a half years ago
I shared with Corey how much debt we
were in when we first got married I
pretty much handled all of the money and
Corey
kind of was just on the back burner he
just worked and just had his head down
when I finally shared how much debt we
were in and he realized how much debt we
were like we have to do something and I
found the seven baby steps we're like
this is it as a mental health therapist
what was it like when realizing
oh we should probably communicate
no not only aided me in my personal
growth but professionally as well
teaching clients to do the same thing so
it's all about communication
intentionality being on the same page
yeah that's very cool okay so what was
the 182 000 what kind of debt it was
primarily student loans we did have a
couple credit cards and Furniture but
um someone went to a private university
okay for six years so yeah so when you
shared it with him you told him right
what he already knew that he was deeply
in debt okay the way you all say that is
so gentle I shared with him the debt no
I told him how much you racked up
yeah I had some as well but his was the
the larger chunk of it yeah okay so he
looked at and said oh yeah this is a
thing so um
talk to me for the sake of the audience
about that dynamic because it's really
important one we're kind of joking
around and laughing over the top of what
is actual some actual pain you were
carrying a lot of stress and uh by you I
mean Amber and
um you kind of went I'm I don't know
what happened you just like I'm at the
end of my rope I can't carry this by
myself anymore or I need some help and
you're not paying attention or what was
what was that Dynamic like
um it was it was pretty much I had to
tell him because we had to change what
we were doing we were we'd go on
vacations but we'd always cash flow it
and then when I get home it's like we
have all this debt left you couldn't
manipulate it enough to make it work and
then when I when I finally shared it
with him because I didn't want to stress
him out when I finally shared the
numbers with him it was eye-opening you
know over the years I've done this for
30 years talking to people in this
situation whether it's the husband that
was doing the bills and has to bring in
the wife or the wife in your case
um there's this weird thing that it's
like I'm supposed to be taking care of
this and I can't I can't do anymore I
don't know how to fix this I've got to
have some help and it's like people feel
sometimes I don't know if you did but
sometimes people feel like like like you
failed at your job which was to take
care of the money and so it's almost a
shame to bring it to the other person
when it actually is their job to help
you but there's this weird thing it's
like oh God I I can't do it there's a
let did you sense that yes okay it's
hard isn't it yes and then there's it's
Dave you just nailed it it's a it's a
stress to shame loop-de-loop because
then you handed him your stress and then
you felt really ashamed about all this
debt you're acting absolutely it's very
challenging but self-compassion is a
very important trait in this journey
without it we wouldn't have been able to
make it yeah it's all good and it made
our our marriage stronger as well yeah
that's a good one so forgiveness right
it goes with compassion yeah like when I
went bankrupt it was completely my fault
Sharon I mean she didn't have any idea
what's going on we've owned houses she
never saw you know I mean it was
completely my fault because I ran the
thing in the ditch and so it took a
little while for me to get over going
you're an idiot I was an idiot but it
took me a little while to get over that
just forgive myself and move on from
that and go I'm just going to learn from
this we're going to take all these
lemons and make some lemonade yeah
there's a real thing to what you guys
have been through it's very powerful
thank you for being open about it and
sharing it you're going to help some
people today by having done that and
you're Victorious too bye goodness 182
000 how does it feel to be free
wonderful wonderful okay now now that
you did it and you leaned in for two and
two years and five months almost two and
a half years
there's a whole Reformation that occurs
during that time and not only in your
relationship but just in the way your
brain looks at money
um a trans formation if you will uh what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
I would say don't focus on what you have
to give up look at what you have to gain
if we would have stayed living how we
were living there's no way that we could
be able to afford the future that we
want and have a house one day so that
would that that's what I would say and
be willing to sacrifice a bit we'd work
seven days a week weekends all our
friends hey do you want to hang out love
what you said one episode Dave no means
just me later a lot of our friends
really stuck to it have some great
support because of that yeah and then we
also really cut down on the grocery
budget and for two and a half years he
had a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
for lunch every single day so that's his
tune officiency
wow yes it's a peanut butter and jelly
protein system yeah that's how you get
those muscles okay yeah that's for sure
oh my God yeah it didn't it didn't kill
him I can tell why
tuna fish sandwiches when we were broke
and I smell tuna fish still to this day
my net worth goes down I just I hate
them I hate tuna fish you know just
because it was broke people food you
know for you it's peanut butter and
jelly you get that smell it's like yo
you have a peanut allergy sir yes I do
I'm completely allergic to peanut butter
and jelly now y'all are y'all are
incredible yeah well done you guys thank
you very well done very well done now
that you're 100 free how's it feel
amazing wonderful cool proud of you very
well done now who are these cheerleaders
who brought with you these are my
parents oh okay they're awful proud just
watching their body language while
you're talking they're just they're just
like ah this they're so proud they were
our biggest supporters yeah when your
grown kids are actually have since it
makes all of us parents proud it really
does it's pretty because we all have
friends that their grown kids are idiots
I mean we do and when you're when
they're not it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool so hey we've got the live and give
bundle for you it's the baby steps
millionaires book which is your next uh
step in this process you'll be there
before you know it uh The Total Money
Makeover book which is what you've just
done maybe you can give it to one of
your friends that stood by you out there
a Financial Peace University membership
as well and again the live and give
bundle we're so proud of you guys you're
a very neat couple what you've been
through is very obvious it's on your
face it's on the way you're looking at
each other it's on the words you're
using you're very powerful very well
done all right it's Corey and Amber
Raleigh North Carolina 182 000 paid off
in two years and five months making 95
to 200 lots of communication lots of
hard work count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one we're
debt free yeah yeah
oh you gotta love it man
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you're a new
listener and we know there's a whole
bunch of you out there that are uh and
all some of this that we talk about is
like tribal speak the vernacular that
we're using the words we're using are
new to you like baby steps and debt
snowballs and all that kind of stuff if
you want to kind of figure out where you
are and start to plug into this whole
thing completely free go to
ramsesolutions.com click on the get
started button ramseysolutions.com click
on the get started button and you know
that'll get you moving in the right
direction get you where you're supposed
to be so our question of the day comes
from neighborly
it's sponsored by neighborly your hub
for Home Services to repair maintain
improve our home researching dozens of
providers as a thing of the past
neighborhoodies all you need to remember
a nationwide network of local home
service pros of all kinds we love
neighborly we're honored that they're
sponsoring us Molly Maid Mr Rooter Mr
Electric to name just a few uh just
really good stuff neighborly.com and you
can get some help near you all right
today's question comes from Molly in
Oregon Molly writes my husband makes
thirty thousand dollars a month take
home well done and I'm fortunate enough
to stay home with my daughter we have
zero debt our rent is currently 2100
bucks a month and utilities are fairly
cheap
we have visited Maui several times and
are planning on making a move there the
thing is I feel like even though we have
no debt in a paid off car and everything
we are still scared to go into debt on a
house we're waiting for a good deal and
think we found something really nice
around 900 Grand
we're making a trip out to see the house
at the end of this month and if that
doesn't work out we have a property we
think we might buy and build a house on
for about the same price are we too
scared to spend money we've just been at
a point in our life when we first got
together where we struggled so much and
I think we both just get scared of being
there again
yeah I mean that's that's the story of
my life yeah you've really helped me
with that one Dave
um I think when your identity is
survival and I say it sounds identity
when your body's trying to survive all
the time
um that that you just develop a scarcity
mindset this all goes away in any second
um and then we live in a world that
tells us it's all coming down it's all
coming down it's all coming down and so
it's really easy thirty thousand dollars
a month is a ton of money and um they
still live like they're broke right
they're still renting
um it's just this Terror that's in there
and you taught me Dave that
in my language you got to practice your
way out of this thing and for me the the
gift that you gave me was practicing
using ratios and to stop looking at
um like for a couple that went broke
nine hundred thousand dollars feels like
a billion right let's look at the ratios
let's look at the cost let's look at the
actual um percentages of things and
that's given me a lot of peace and
allowed me to practice a new way of
doing life well it helps your use your
uh intellect your your brain to make the
decision on facts it's bringing my my
brain back online yeah I'm using facts
instead of feelings that's right because
what happens is there's two there's two
things that cause two situations and
they usually go together actually
um number one if you've gone broke like
I have
um then you are like she has in this
situation you're you know you have to
heal from that and the only way you heal
from that it move from this I'm always
going to be broke mentality to I'm never
going to be there again mentality is you
have to practice and you have to do new
things the second thing that happens is
when you start and you are making thirty
thousand dollars a year
and then you're making thirty thousand
dollars a month
what happens is the math grew faster
than your emotional capacity
to manage that now I'm not saying you
have the intellectual capacity to manage
the money I'm saying that you know I'll
give an example around here at Ramsey
okay I mean I grew up normal kid right
and I worked my butt off cutting grass
and doing everything else shoveling
whatever had to be shovel all this kind
of stuff right and what we spend on
coffee
at Ramsey with 1100 employees I I never
made that much in a year right and we
spent it on coffee oh my God you know I
mean it's just like to get my emotional
head around those numbers sometimes I
have it's an intellectual exercise you
know what we spent on copier paper
in a building that it's just like
because of the scale right you know and
it's like and we're not doing anything
wrong it's nothing irresponsible the
coffee is not ridiculous it's not
Starbucks I don't even like Starbucks
and so uh but it's it's not it's not
inexpensive coffee it's not expensive
it's just good coffee but you know it's
not that it's just there's a lot of it
right and so the same thing's true when
you're buying a uh you know you've been
driving a five thousand dollar or eight
thousand dollar car that breaks down and
the tires are bare for the majority of
your life to emotionally buy a 50 000
car even if you're worth 10 million
dollars doesn't matter it's a difficult
decision because you feel like weird
yeah because your your emotions are not
used to sitting in that car your nose is
not used to smelling that smell
you know the new car smell it it doesn't
come up well for us so for for Sheila
and I we when we bought our our house in
in Texas
um
I I had a great job she did a great job
I could not believe that a human being
would spend this much money on house
Dave I didn't sleep for two or three
days couldn't breathe
um when we bought it and we closed we
went in with the key opened it up Sheila
fell to the floor crying she could never
believe have believed that she could
live in such opulence and we sold the
house and I made enough money to pay
cash for like a fifteen thousand dollar
truck so he made a little money on it
and we got 185 for it and then we moved
to Nashville
and you you can't buy somebody's you
can't I mean
here's the thing I had and uh I'll I'll
use the word sinfully I had lumped
people who buy houses that cost this
much cost this much money into those are
those people where are these people and
people like us I had divided the world
up into us as in them's in in an unfair
way sometimes people do that on Race
sometimes on education level and
religion sometimes they do it based on
the fact they've been broke right or
they grew up broke
a friend of mine grew up in the hood and
he said getting out of the Hood's easier
and getting the hood out of you
uh huh you know and that's the truth
that's the thing and so the the what
we're saying is every one of us have had
down times or broke times or made more
money than we ever made in our life and
it is a it is normal for your emotions
to struggle to catch up so Molly you're
normal yes by the house yes the way you
fix this is you you have to do what John
says about trauma of any kind you have
to say facts are your friends these
fears are irrational and so if you have
six hundred thousand dollars cash in
your bank account and you want to buy a
fifteen thousand dollar car it you know
and you have a weird feeling it ain't
the math Bubba it's you it acknowledge
the feeling acknowledge it I have a
little thing that I write them down I
still write them down yeah when they're
obnoxious and they're dumb I write them
down and then we move on yeah and
because it takes the power away from
that's right that's right Stacy's in
Fort Worth Texas hi Stacy how are you
so much for taking my call
too what's up
um so we have we have a daughter who's
in college and then our younger our
twins who will be going off to college
in the fall
and we we had a very lengthy not your
normal baby step two and it's left us
with a house that needs repair on
everything and so I was my question for
you is would it financially make sense
to just sort of um get rid of the house
as is
um you know sell it to one of those
companies that just takes it off your
hands no they take it off your hands at
wholesale you need to call a good real
estate agent and have them come in and
say these are there's 10 things you
could do six of them are worth the money
the other four you need to let the other
people do
whatever it is okay but if you'll spend
the money on paint on Landscaping on the
re-carpet it's going to 2x your return
when you get ready to sell the house and
you're going to get the enjoyment of it
so you need to make a list of projects
the way you eat an elephant is a bite at
a time that's your real estate agent
your future real estate agent gives you
the priority on this is the most
important one down to the least
important one and work your way down
those projects with cash and then some
of them you don't need to do because
they're not worth doing we'll let the
next owner do it but it's a retail buyer
not a We Buy Houses buyer so we buy
houses buyers a wholesale buyer and you
don't need to take that hit because you
don't have the energy to fix this house
get the house fixed up get a real estate
agent to guide you through it give
multiple bids prioritize it work one
project at a time you don't have to do
them all at once and you don't go into
debt to do this
so good question you're on your way
you're on your way Stacy you're closer
than you feel like this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they actually love
and create real actual amazing
relationships the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Dr John deloney host of the Dr John
deloney show is my co-host today he's
also the number one best-selling author
of the book on your past change your
future Sarah is in Detroit Michigan hi
Sarah welcome to the Ramsay show
sure what's up
father-in-law bought a home for my
husband's ex-wife to live in
about 15 years ago
stop stop stop stop stop stop this
sounds a hillbilly already I'm having
trouble what what in the world
your husband's ex-wife a house to live
in
pull out back
you know I I don't understand the
situation at all my family doesn't do
things like this no normal people don't
do crap like this
it usually is the other way around I
mean you know Byron no oh my goodness
okay so he after the divorce maybe he's
taking care of the kids maybe that's it
was his grandkids
yeah it is somewhat more sane okay but
still stupid but okay
at the time they had um two teenagers
and um I think that I think he uh one
was about 10 years old
so this was about 15 years ago so she's
lived there since then
um she doesn't pay rent father-in-law
has up kept the home and well the house
is not in her name he bought it and lets
her live there
yes and kept the house in his name okay
good okay that's better even okay
is it yeah this is going to be a
supernova I can't wait this is gonna be
great
so
um kids are grown now she still lives
there and I just happened to see a piece
of paper
that said
um title um on death the title to go
over to my husband when my father-in-law
passes away
so I guess my father-in-law is expecting
my husband to keep the house up and no
um I don't care what he expects no
as my wife told me once John I'm not
doing chores for you after you're dead
okay so here's the thing uh regardless
of how it occurred where it is today is
stupidville can we agree with that
yeah so your your husband needs to go
sit down have a cup of coffee with his
dad and say Dad uh I don't want to have
to deal with this crap you need to deal
with it now
uh ex-wife doesn't have a reason to live
there anymore free the kids are grown
and gone she needs to move on now
it's not mean it's weird
it's weird just say it out loud it's
lived rent free for 15. he did it
because he's a Grandpa's heart I got it
I got a Grandpa's heart right and
Grandpa's heart sometimes because you do
stupid butt things and he did a stupid
butt thing but he needs to handle this
before he dies
what yeah okay so I don't even know I
can hear in your voice he's not going to
so is your husband a wush when it comes
to his dad
a little bit no of course he is he
bought his ex-wife a house of course
yeah okay so here here you really you
need to give your run down to Walmart
and pick your husband up a backbone
they're on all three and you need to
send him on over to his dad and say Dad
I don't want this house unless you move
her out
before you die
because I don't have to deal with her
she's my ex for a reason
we don't want the house take my name off
the deed or get her out one of the two
because I'm not going to have to deal
with evicting my ex-wife because the day
the day you inherit this she gets
evicted
if she doesn't move voluntarily
right which I don't think she will is he
a free ride that comes to an end to my
girl time to move and when Dave starts
talking French you know he's serious
that's hillbilly French right there oh
yeah redneck that's just not this is
dumb go ahead Sarah
would it be an option for him to instead
just feed the house over to the ex-wife
since he wanted to if he wants to give
it to her and give it to her I don't
care this is a weird freaking family
okay but I if I'm in your shoes I want
to tell you what I'm trying to do with
all my sarcasm and bombasticness is you
think this is crazy and you're right
that's what I'm trying to do is affirm
you your feelings about this are
completely correct this is strangeville
stupidville weirdville okay let me let
me affirm one more time there are three
towns right together and the
intersection is your ex his ex-wife's
house okay
Sarah there's 22 million people listen
to this going oh my God there's another
layer to this
also
you're realizing in real time your
husband is uh like Dave Dave eloquently
said doesn't have a backbone and hasn't
dealt with something that should have
been dealt with a long long time ago and
it's right for you to also feel that
sense of who who is this guy when things
get sideways he just goes on so it's
gonna be okay this is XY this is
somebody that's out of his life they
went through a legal process
so you're right to call him on that as
well
you'll need to have that conversation
because you're losing respect for him
right
here's the thing he's going to deal with
it or he's going to deal with it or he's
going to deal with you
he's going to deal with it with his dad
he's going to deal with evicting her
after he gets the house or he's going to
deal with you he gets to deal with this
it's not an option
he just gets to choose what he deals
with
and the easiest path is go sit down have
a cup of coffee with his nutty father
Dad no I don't want this house no I
don't want your timeshare either don't
leave me that either both of them are
dumb right I don't want this and if Dad
won't deal with it then you two need to
decide
um are we gonna go through illegal
proceeding and evict her and sell this
house and she's going to sue us and all
that oral deed the house over to her and
just walk no no I'm not giving it to her
there's no way there's no way she just
needs to leave this is this woman has
had I've had enough of this woman
already this new this woman needs to
move out of this house okay my God what
a freeloader and so no okay I was
feeling guilty no you don't need to feel
guilty this is dumber than a rock
so here's what okay here's the steps if
it's me you need to sit down with your
husband and the two of you need to
address the fact that he won't address
this John's right because this is going
to put a splinter in your own
relationship you don't want to leave
there number two then he needs to go
really he does need to go sit down talk
to his dad very calmly nicely he doesn't
have to be as crazy as I'm being on the
air I'm doing that to give you strength
and remind you that you're normal and
that what you're thinking is real
because the voices I just gave were also
in your head so I'm just I'm just saying
them out in the loud okay now he sits
down with his dad calmly and says Dad
this is weird I don't have to deal with
this I don't want to deal with her
that's why she's my ex and you need to
move her out of there before you die or
you need to take my name off of this
whole thing if Dad won't deal with it
and he leaves him the thing the instant
dad is ill your husband needs to tell
his ex-wife she has 30 days and we're
going to be selling the house you've got
to move
and your husband needs to handle this
none of this are you responsible for he
has to man up
and handle this it's his freaking family
and his freaking mess and he's got to do
it and you got to kick him hard enough
to get him to do it this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America it is a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five
paying off debt smart saving and
investing is smart being outrageously
generous is smart there's one key to
winning with money that people Overlook
and that's protecting your finances from
emergencies and this is where the right
kinds of insurance come in and that's
smart there are 10 kinds of insurance
that might be smart for you we've built
a free tool called the coverage checkup
to show you which types are smart which
wants to add drop or adjust drop the
dumb ones keep the Smart Ones we'll show
you how it works and it's all free and
it's fast takes about five minutes you
need to go to ramsesolutions.com checkup
ramseysolutions.com checkup don't let an
emergency sneak up on you protect your
family now
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Peter is with
us in Columbus Ohio hi Peter welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey good afternoon gentlemen thanks for
the time today sure how can we help
a question for you my wife and I are on
baby four five and six we recently
bought our first house as a family uh we
put down about 300 so we only have about
100 left on it we have 30 000 in a 529
and we make household income about 110 a
year uh we currently pay about 12 000 a
year in daycare and we're looking at
sending our son uh to private school and
we figured tuition is probably going to
be roughly what we pay in daycare today
uh kicker is we're uh older parents I'm
50. my wife's in her early 40s and we
had a three-year-old son so question is
would it be wise to draw down a portion
of that 529 to pay for the private to
pay for a portion of the private school
tuition which would allow us to pay down
our mortgage faster in with the thought
being that having a paid off house would
make College easier to cash flow later
hmm
I wouldn't call it Dom I'm struggling
with it from a timing standpoint because
I'm thinking of all the uh
I always think of the downsides because
I always get to deal with people when
their plan didn't work because life blew
up right and so how could life blow up
and mess up this plan okay you're an
older parent uh let's say Ford Junior
gets to college you die
well your plan didn't work because
you're not there to cash flow College
you with me right that that bothers me
because we drained this 401 or we joined
us 529 so that he could go to private
Christian kindergarten
and we traded that for college
um yeah not making that trade
um I'm on a cash floater I'm not doing
it
Tesla that that private school too yeah
in the short term yeah okay yeah because
I need that I need that Nest Egg there
to back him up if you're not there to
back him up
yeah that makes sense we were just
saying the other night when we were
talking about it uh you know it would
make this decision a lot easier if we
knew what the future
yeah you get that one figured out let me
know I'll I'll help you franchise it but
yeah yeah I think Michael J fox figured
that out for you he's got three
installments you can watch oh thanks
great thank you for the future yeah that
one yeah careful yeah okay I didn't know
what you're talking about there for a
second appreciate it yeah Back to the
Future there yeah um
I tell you what I don't know if I want
to go here you can just say let's move
on
I get I get more blown up on social
media like the people who follow me are
so kind I get blown up on one issue one
no two travel Sports and the other one
is I send my kids to public school
and well I can help you with that I'll
just tell you I'll take the heat yeah
it's a
all three Ramses went to Public Schools
yeah and none of the three rooms used to
travel Sports
because Daniel was pretty good at ice
hockey but he wasn't gonna be playing in
the NHL yeah so I'm not dropping 15
grand a year for the kid to play travel
Sports and me be out of town every
weekend uh he ain't gonna make it yeah
well but I'm going back to what this guy
was talking about with
I mean he's talking about literally
mortgaging his future
for
this to get my kids out of this school
so they can come to this school well
he's going to send him to the private
Christian School that was not an issue
it was just how to pay for it was the
only question
yeah and so uh now then he didn't ask if
we thought it was a good idea you know
that wasn't the point but yeah there's
uh uh
you know there's when someone wants to
go to a private Christian School there
is usually uh one of two or three
reasons yeah uh one is they live in a
neighborhood where the public schools
aren't they don't perceive them as being
safe yeah okay
um and another rough rough area yeah
okay uh two is they want to ensure that
the teaching is done from a Christian
world view not with all the wackadoodle
right that uh that truthfully a lot of
the teachers unions and other things are
put into the schools now there's
whackadoodle in the schools yeah and
they don't want their kids in there and
a post the other day uh he said yeah he
had homeschool kids and he's like people
tell my kids tell me what about prop you
know of homeschool children they're not
going to be properly socialized they
want socialized by drag queens I mean
really thank you no thank you I don't
want to be socialized by drag queens so
Alma School is a really good idea yeah
it's really a good point actually so so
but the idea is well
what's the third one
so safety
um religion yeah and academics
okay sometimes the academics are better
yeah they want to go to I it's not
always a private Christian school but a
private school for a better for better
academics and so like in our
neighborhood we have uh in our
neighborhood here I won't name it we
have a private school that's well known
it does have a Christian uh underpinning
or background or or but it also claim
walks around claiming to have uh better
academics gotcha but the graduation from
college rate is exactly the same as the
public school that's a mile and a half
down the road right exactly and uh and
it's it's like 30 000 bucks a year yeah
you know per kit sure so uh you just
gotta decide is it worth it like you
decide if you're going to go to a
college yeah that's more expensive why
what is the value proposition in that
case and you know I think there is some
something to be said uh and the more
wackadoodle the world gets on just world
view of the teaching staff yeah it's
that you know I don't want whackadoo to
talk to my grandkids okay now we live in
a weird bubble where our public schools
in this County are unusually the number
one in the in the state they're
incredible yeah and number one in the
state and the people in our
general area here share our values Yeah
by and large there's there's a few
wackadoodles out there but I mean most
the people are like normal humans
they're not aliens teaching in the
classroom uh like you read about on sure
you know in the news and everything but
uh so you know we've we're a little bit
spoiled yeah in that regard so where
Hank goes or where my grandkids go to
public school yeah all of my grandkids
go to public school but that public
school is better than
a whole lot of private schools in a
whole lot of ways right right so but
it's unusual not all public you can say
that about so anyway
um
you know you just got to look at the
situation but yeah I get blown up on
that too because this idea that I mean
if you've got extra money yeah and you
want to spend I mean Rachel did uh
competition cheerleading sure two years
yeah and we paid some money for her to
go to the gymnast thing and learn how to
do flips off the somebody's shoulders or
whatever it was she did and um and then
I think we went to one competition in
Atlanta or something where she flipped
or whatever but
um it's you know today as a 34 year old
mom and best-selling author of three
books uh has not done a single flip
lately
it's not come up again you know yeah
yeah so um uh that's but it's okay
there's a weird thing that goes with
that travel Sports thing and it's the
same I think it's the same button you're
pushing with a private school thing well
I I had a unique perspective of dealing
with students whose parents outsourced
they hid their their kids from these
conversations never had them never had
them and then they show up in college
and in the world's sideways yeah and so
there's something about I love the idea
of my kids hearing things and being
challenged and then coming home to me
yeah yeah not to their 19 year old
roommate right so about how life Works
about there's just people with whacking
new ideas out there is God real yeah
let's have some conversations at home
about this by the way I'm not
Outsourcing that my children's
spirituality but yeah you betcha this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey guys listen up our
brand new Ramsey Events Center is going
to be opening to the public with our
inaugural event in two weeks April 14th
and 15th we're going to be doing our
very first live event there the
Nashville smart conference we're going
to be doing this show live from the
stage there there are some free tickets
to watch that left if you want to check
our website at ramsaysolutions.com
events and then the smart conference is
Friday evening and all day Saturday
teaching you everything about all the
different areas that we teach on from
jobs work and career to money and
Investments to just getting better at
life and of course relationships and
mental Wellness with Dr John deloney all
of that's going to be there there's 2500
seats in there it is almost sold out
there are 71 seats left
if you want to come
it's only 119 you're going to get an
inaugural pass you're going to be the
first one ever to be at a live event in
that in terms of the public in that
particular building and we're looking
forward to having you
ramseysolutions.com events come on out
we'd love to have you all right Desmond
and Clark uh Sierra are with us on the
debt free stage hey guys how are you
we're doing well did I say that right is
it Sierra it is Sierra okay great good
to have you guys where do you live we
are in Atlanta Georgia fun welcome to
Nashville how much debt have you paid
off we paid off a hundred and thirty
thousand all right how long did this
take it took us about four years all
right and uh what was your range of
income during that time uh we started
out about 80 and then we ended up about
000. very good what do you do for a
living uh we're both special education
teachers oh wow what a great calling wow
that's where I take a moment of silence
y'all are incredible yeah incredible
fabulous well done all right and uh what
kind of debt was this 130 000. it was
all student loans student loans all
right so how long have you all been
married
we will be celebrating 12 years of
marriage this may so eight years into
your marriage you looked up and said
there's an unwelcome person in our house
her name is Sally May yes we need to
evict this old woman she'd be ugly tell
me the story what happened well it
actually started when I was in college I
got introduced to financial peace from
my Chick-fil-A owner operator Luke go
Luke he was a coordinator at the church
that he was attending and he challenged
us to go through the the class and and I
just went through it and it was good
um and you failed the class you flunked
you did nothing I flunked the class did
nothing but it was instant you know the
principles were instilled in me and I
always wanted to do it
and so one of the things uh one of the
funny stories is I had a difference
check and I actually paid for her
engagement ring with the difference
after the class you know of course you
did I failed the class oh let's just say
that that's all right okay so you got
you got her a ring though I got her you
got the girl I got the girl all right
and now we start living now what was the
wake-up call at four years ago well um I
had a very long journey getting through
school I had challenges with choosing
what I wanted to major in and so it took
me a long time to finish and so Desmond
said once you finish school in 2017 it
is time for us to get started we know
the principles we know what to do it's a
matter of doing it of course he was
ready to go but I was like um it took me
a long time to get through school I'm
not trying to pay nobody's debt I want
to have fun I want to spend money so it
took a while for my heart to catch up
with what I knew I needed to do in my
head and after listening to me mini Dave
Ramsey shows morning noon and night and
um
the worst date in Atlanta
he did we listened to it so often and
even going through um rock solid
finances which actually taught how to
Steward money from a Biblical
perspective a mixture of all of that
actually allowed my heart to catch up
with what I knew I needed to do and so
we got started all right and so once she
comes on board it's game on it was game
on we started chunking everything at the
dead when she got her teaching job that
kind of boosted our income so we just
started doing all sorts of things I I
got a bus driver's license just to be
able to get extra money wow we were I
coached uh she took extra side hustles
and so we just it was game on and we
just went on with it well good for you
guys well all right so take me to 10
months in
oh like the adrenaline's worn off you're
you're already done what kept y'all
going
um actually we're recording we uh we're
coordinators Financial Peace
coordinators so we use that to kind of
help us to keep the motivation going and
so that helped you know because we had
to live it uh you know teaching the
class and everything and so those types
of things continuing to listen to the
Ramsey show that free screens getting
motivated I mean that's what kept us
going yes and also having little
Milestones along the way because I'm a
shopper I like to shop and I'm like look
if we're gonna do this like I need to
have some moments where we can celebrate
what we make meet a payment goal and so
having those those moments along the way
was very so what kind of celebrations
did you do so one time we went to the
Fox Theater in Atlanta we went to go see
The Lion King live oh so that was a big
celebration but we had to pay off a
large lump sum before we yeah but that's
a good that's good yes it was little
little things here and there to kind of
keep us motivated and keep us going
carrots to dangle yes yes
so what's it feel like to owe nobody
nothing oh so free we were talking about
that earlier today it just feels freeing
to not have that weight over you anymore
and to not owe anybody anything so it
feels great yes you know I was talking
to somebody the other day they said they
felt grown up isn't that weird yeah it's
like like I I made the little kid inside
me behave so that I could be like doing
grown-up stuff and that was a pretty
cool thing I like that visual a lot
because that's what happened to me yeah
you know that's how I felt and because I
remember going to I used to think when
you went to Costco or Sam's like you had
to leave with 200 worth of stuff like it
was federal law yeah like that's why
they check your receipt on the way out
they want to make sure you spent your
200 bucks right you got to go back in
Dave get some more peanut butter man so
get that eight gallons right and I I
mean I don't know what it is but it's
weird and so well congratulations y'all
thank you very very proud Sierra have
you been on a barn burner shopping spree
yet
um yes I have I'm not going to lie to
you I have that was always the struggle
that that line out of in the budget yeah
close and we always had a 30 to 15
minute argument over there let the
record show that they have foil t-shirts
you look incredible they look amazing
live like no one else I'm thinking
Desmond had nothing to do with these
t-shirts I did I did yeah
did you produce them a teacher friend of
mine created the shirts okay yes I love
it very good okay they look great they
look great on camera you bring us one uh
no but we can get you one well you can
get you one
I love it it's an awesome way to go you
guys all right what do you tell people
the key you're leading a class now
you're and one thing about Leading The
Clash like you said you can't be a
hypocrite and sometimes that's a bigger
motivator than doing it for yourself but
uh uh you're leading the class what's
the secret to getting out of debt
well one thing that helped us to get out
of debt was definitely remembering our
why you know we both grew up in single
parent single income homes and so we got
to witness what the struggle was like to
make ends meet and we said we wanted
something different for the royal family
we didn't want to live in debt and that
verse comes to mind constantly the
borrower was a slave to A lender we
didn't want to be asleep we wanted to
free ourselves and so that's the key
that kept us going well you are the
Royal Family
come on that's my last name my last name
rhymes with the lunch meat dude
you got deloni bologna and we have the
Royals we've got the royal family good
grief that's perfect the royal family
should have a better life I'm just
saying what's your key Desmond my key
with the discipline I'm needed in
Hebrews 12 11 we got that on our back
yeah no discipline seems Pleasant at the
time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness and that's so true we just
struggled you know it's tough while
you're in it you know but if you keep
pushing along it's it's you can get to
the other side so we probably don't ever
and I will add one more thing making
sure that you have some good
accountability it is a tough journey and
so having some accountability along the
way is also helpful amen Desmond and
Sierra 130 000 paid off in four years
making 80 to 115. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're dead free
[Applause]
congratulations wow
change the Royal Family
[Music]
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our scripture today is
James 1 5-6 if any of you lacks wisdom
you should ask God
who gives generously to all without
finding fault and it will be given to
you
but when you ask you must believe and
not doubt because the one who doubts is
like a wave of the sea blown and tossed
by the wind
Theodore Roosevelt said in any moment of
decision the best thing you can do is
the right thing the next best thing you
think is the wrong thing the worst thing
you can do is nothing
I like that it's good Emily's with us in
Dallas Texas hi Emily welcome to the
Ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
sure how can we help
okay so my husband and I we make uh 247
000 uh we are debt free
um and I've been working full-time right
now and going to law school
um so I've been cash flowing my way I
graduate next month and so for the first
time I'm able because all my money was
going to law school for the first time
I'm able to invest my money
um my company has a 401k but they don't
have a match and then because of our
high income we can I can't invest into a
four uh Roth IRA sorry and so my
question is should I should I just go
ahead and invest in my firms 401k or is
there a better route of investing wow
and you're 100 debt free
yes okay way to go that's incredible
Emily congratulations hard very cool and
you've landed your law job
yes I'm working on my Law Firm now and
they're just waiting for we're actually
just waiting for bar results next week
wow what a wonderful time for you
congratulations no actually Dave this is
the worst time the week before the bar
comes up no it's waiting waiting is hard
but I mean this is all the work is done
oh yeah I mean you've been you've worked
for a long time to be sitting here right
now incredible way to go all right um so
the answer your question is uh what
about a house have y'all got a home
yes we do do you owe anything on it
uh yeah
yes we owe about
half or maybe like 100
okay you owe 150 000 on your home you
say we you're married
yes and your household income is what
247. excellent excellent excellent
excellent okay do you have any money in
savings
yes I have about ten thousand
um and then uh we used to have them put
our savings together how long have you
been married
uh we've been married about two years
okay put them together tonight
okay if you can share a bed you can
share a bank account
okay
all the date because all the data is
people who try to live like roommates
don't have anywhere near the relational
success nor the financial success
all the data says couples that combine
their finances combine their goals
combine their fears combine their dreams
charging forward are the couples that
have the most wealth built and the best
quality relationships so that's where
that comes from I didn't just make that
up and let me tell you this Emily um
you my my nerd research was on the
mental health of attorneys of lawyers
was it really yeah and listen wow all of
your training and your job is you are
outside the bell curve your whole life
is dedicated to serving and loving
people who's the the things that don't
happen to the rest of us all the time
happen to them which means you lived
outside the bell curve which means all
the marriages you read about and
experience are ones that blew up
and so it's really common to start
creating little pockets in your life of
safety like I'm gonna have my savings
he's gonna have his
she said she'd do it tonight but but
yeah but it's still good speech she's
not oh really yes so Emily
you have to decide right now I'm gonna
live this life because the world needs
attorneys I I'm I'm I'm pro-atturnee to
to the end but
you have to decide we're going to do
this the right way and we're going to
choose to Buck the system and be United
in this thing or it's it's just gonna
crumble underneath you okay back to your
question back to your question here's
what you do we're going to walk you
through what we call the baby steps the
first thing you need to have as a couple
is an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses so I'm gonna call
that in Euros World Thirty or forty
thousand dollars cash you never touch
that except for a rainy day an emergency
an unexpected event in other words you
never touch it because you make enough
money to cover ninety percent of your
unexpected events out of your cash flow
okay but this is a something big blows
up and you got an extra 30 grand land
over here that the two of you say that's
Grandma's rainy day funding you know
what that means right and so you got
that once you've got that then I want
you to save 15 of your household income
into retirement no more and that's baby
step four five is pay is start saving
for kids college you know many kids yet
so we're not doing that I think you
don't have any kids yet you don't have
any kids yet right
no no kidding okay so no kids so we
don't need to do baby step five which is
kids college baby step six is while
we're putting 15 of our income away
towards retirement we're gonna throw the
rest of the money we get that that we
can that we have a slush money above
living a reasonably good life I mean you
make really good money so you live a
good life throw the rest of the extra
money at the house until the house has
paid off
so what I'm saying is we if we Mac if we
don't need to max out retirement to get
to that
15 then we don't have to worry about
your question but let's go ahead and
walk it through anyway if at so the
first thing I want to do is I want to do
Roth our first thing I want to do is do
a match you said your company does not
match does your husband's company match
yes he's I think he's investing about 12
and she has like an eight percent match
all I care about is the total of your
household between the two of you the
total is 15 going in not you 15 him 15.
that would actually meet B15 but he
could put in 12 and you could put in
more than and you could put in 17 as
long as the total is 15 of the total
household income you follow me
yeah okay so that's what I'm after
everything above that goes to the
mortgage so I want you to max out your
401K on him to max out his 401k
um and I want them to be in Roth 401ks
if Roth is available Roth is better than
traditional because it grows tax-free
the only thing better than Roth is Roth
with a match
and he's got a match you don't but we're
still going to make sure it's out it's
going to take that probably to get to 15
of your huge income
so and then you can do Roth IRAs they're
called back door roths and you can do
those with a good investment broker if
you don't have one uh go to
ramsaysolutions.com click on smartvestor
the people we recommend will be there
and you can choose one from the list
they're really good and they'll show you
how this works the raw the backdoor Roth
IRA is I do one and my income is well in
excess of the Max and all it is is you
open a a traditional uh I'm sorry an
after-tax traditional IRA and you fully
fund it and 30 seconds later you flip it
to a Roth it creates no taxes and it's
an after-tax traditional I can do that
at any income limit and then flip it to
a Roth that's called a backdoor Roth I
do those every January for me and Sharon
and it's not that much it's only six or
eight grand depending on your age and
all that but that's you know you can
still do that and that'll those things
will get you to that 15 percent but when
you get to 15 of your total household
income going into your total retirement
between roths backdoor roths 401ks his
401k yours Roth 401ks are available to
those whatever Hoover's got the match
ought to go there first that's him uh
when you get to 15 stop and throw
everything else towards the mortgage
until the mortgage is clear when the
mortgage is clear then you max out
everything else then once everything's
Max Dave beyond the back door roths and
both 401ks then what do I do then I buy
mutual funds that have a low turnover
ratio which does not activate the
capital gains because they don't sell
the tax the stocks inside of them very
often that's a low turnover issue or I
buy real estate that I pay cash for but
you're not going to be there for a
couple of years
because you still got a house to pay off
and that's where we're going to get to
wow that's interesting about attorneys I
did not know that we do need attorneys
because we need attorney jokes we need
lawyer jokes no we need people who are
rational third parties that keep people
like me who are the Hot Heads from
uh
doing dumb things yeah you know you've
had different experience with some
attorneys than that but yeah okay I've
had some rough ones some very very rough
ones I got some good ones that are
friends and some of them on our team and
all that that work here I like them
really but they really give me a hard
time about ripping on attorneys so but
it's fun it's fun hey Emily we're very
proud of you good luck that puts us out
of the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]